-- DESPERATION.
AS THE MEDIA LIKES TO SAY, ARE
THE WALLS CLOSING IN?
JONATHAN TURLEY, I WANT TO FOCUS
IN ON THIS ISSUE OF
INTIMIDATION.
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT WHEN I READ
"THE WASHINGTON POST" ARTICLE,
IT SEEMS TO TALK ABOUT
INTIMIDATING WITNESSES.
INTIMIDATING INVESTIGATORS, AND
INTIMIDATING ANYONE IN THE MEDIA
THAT THERE IS TO TALK ABOUT
STUFF THAT WE KNOW TO BE ON THE
PUBLIC RECORD.
DOES THAT READ THE SAME WAY TO
YOU?
>> THAT'S HOW IT LOOKED TO ME.
IT'S NOT UNCOMMON TO MAKE THESE
ATTACK MACHINES.
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO COME OUT
SPONTANEOUSLY TO GIVE THE
APPEARANCE THEY'RE NOT BEING
ORGANIZED.
IT IS VERY UNCOMMON TO HAVE THIS
ALL LATE OUT IN "THE WASHINGTON
POST" NAMING TARGETS THAT HAPPEN
TO INCLUDE THE TWO CHIEF
WITNESSES THAT ARE CONTRADICTING
THE BIDENS.
THAT SEEMS TO BE AN EFFORT TO
PUT A SHOT ACROSS THEIR BOUGH
SAYING THEY'RE COMING FOR YOU.
WHY IS IT IMPORTANT FOR THEM NOW
BEFORE SUBPOENAS ARE ISSUED OR
TESTIMONY IS GIVEN TO ISSUE THIS
WARNING SHOT?
AND I THINK IT COULD EASILY BE
READ AS AN EFFORT TO CHILL
PEOPLE IF NOT INTIMIDATE THEM IF
YOU'RE GOING TO COVER THIS
STORY, THEY'RE PREPARING
DEFAMATION LAWSUITS IN
RETALIATION.
>> HANNITY: HOW DAMNING IS IT IN
YOUR VIEW, PROFESSOR, THAT JOE
BIDEN REPEATEDLY SAID HE NEVER
HAD A SINGLE CONVERSATION WITH
HUNTER OR ANYONE ELSE IN THE
FAMILY ABOUT THEIR FOREIGN
BUSINESS DEALINGS, BUT, YET, WE
HAVE PHOTOGRAPHIC EVIDENCE AND
REPORTS AS MANY AS 14 MEETINGS
THAT THEY CAN IDENTIFY OF
HUNTER, JOE, AND FOREIGN
BUSINESS PARTNERS.
HOW DAMNING IS THAT?
>> I THINK THAT'S WHAT'S IN THE
ARTICLE.
THEY'RE GOING TO THE SCORCHED
EARTH CAMPAIGN. THERE'S NOT A
LOT LEFT.
THE STATEMENT MADE BY BIDEN
APPEARS CLEARLY AND
UNEQUIVOCALLY FALSE.
HE SAID HE HAD NO KNOWLEDGE, NO
DISCUSSIONS ON HIS SON'S FOREIGN
DEALINGS.
>> EVER.
>> THERE ARE PICTURES OF HIM
MEETING WITH THE BUSINESS
EXECUTIVES.
THERE ARE EMAILS GOING BACK AND
FORTH.
AND THE PERSON WHO WAS MOST
THREATENED IN THAT "WASHINGTON
POST" ARTICLE, BOBALENSKI IS THE
GUY WHO IS THE GREATEST THREAT
TO BIDEN BECAUSE HE SAID HE MET
WITH BIDEN TO DISCUSS THESE
DEALS.
HE WAS BROUGHT IN TO HELP TO
MANAGE THOSE.
IT'S CLEAR THEY'VE DECLARED OPEN
SEASON TO PROTECT THE BIDENS.
>> HANNITY: IF THE LIED ABOUT
NEVER SPEAKING TO HIS FAMILY
ABOUT THE FOREIGN BUSINESS
OPERATIONS, IF THE MET WITH THE
FOREIGN BUSINESS PARTNERS OF
HUNTER, IF IT CAN BE PROVEN
ABOUT THE FACT THAT HE
FINANCIALLY BENEFITTED FROM
THESE MEETINGS.
FOR EXAMPLE, AN IMPLICATION BY
HUNTER HE WAS TIRED OF GIVING
HALF OF THE INCOME TO POPS OR
PAYING FOR REPAIRS ON HIS
FATHER'S HOME, ETC., IF THE
MONEY SIDE OF THIS IS PROVEN,
WHAT IS THE LEGAL POTENTIAL
LIABILITY FOR JOE BIDEN, THE.
PRESIDENT BECAUSE HE SAID THIS
IS AN INVESTIGATION INTO THE OF
THE UNITED STATES.
HE DIDN'T SAY HUNTER.
>> IT'S NOT THE CRIME BUT THE
COVER-UP THAT GETS PEOPLE IN TO
TROUBLE.
INFLUENCE PEDALING IS A COTTAGE
INDUSTRY IN WASHINGTON.
I'VE BEEN A CRITIC OF THIS
CORRUPTION FOR DECK CASE.
-- DECADES.
I'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING TO THE
SCALE OF WHAT THE BIDEN FAMILY
APPEARS TO HAVE DONE.
THE PROBLEMS THEY HAVE ARE ALL
OF THE STATEMENTS THAT APPEAR
NOW TO BE FALSE.
INFLUENCE PEDALING IN AND OF
ITSELF MAY NOT BE A CRIME.
BUT THE MEANS YOU USE TO COMMIT
INFLUENCE PEDDLING AND THE MEANS
YOU USE TO COVER IT UP CAN BE.
THERE ARE FOREIGN TRANSFERS THAT
THE HOUSE IS GOING TO BE LOOKING
AT.
THERE ARE TAX ISSUES THAT ARE
ALREADY UNDER INVESTIGATION.
BUT THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF PEOPLE
INTERVIEWED BY FEDERAL AGENTS.
THAT TENDS TO BE THE AREA WHERE
YOU FIND THE GREATEST DANGER OF
PROSECUTION IS MAKING A FALSE
STATEMENT TO A FEDERAL AGENT.
NOW, ON TOP OF ALL OF THAT, THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES APPEARS
READY TO ISSUE A STORM OF
SUBPOENAS.
THAT'S GOING TO INCREASE THE
RISK FOR PEOPLE AROUND THE
BIDENS.
AND I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS WE'RE SEEING THIS
PREANNOUNCEMENT OF A SCORCHED
EARTH CAMPAIGN, TO TRY TO GET
PEOPLE TO THINK THAT YOU HAVE --
YOU DO PROCEED AT YOUR OWN
PERIL.
>> HANNITY: I VENTURE TO GUESS
YOUR NAME MAY BE ON THE LIST
WITH MY NAME.
I'M GUESSING.